And everybody, this is Dr. Erick Cutters again, the three phases of Lyme course and we're
going to go over really the four steps that we talk about when you're trying to heal
from this could be really any chronic disease, but certainly any autoimmune condition you
need to deal with these four steps.
So we're talking about phase three autoimmune stage Lyme, but any autoimmune disease this
really applies to.
So understand, an autoimmune disease is simply antibodies that are been created by your own
B cell response to any self tissue.
So whatever autoimmune disease you have, it's named by the antibodies and what tissue
you have those auto those antibodies created to could be rheumatoid arthritis, could be
Hashimoto's, could be Graves disease, Hashimoto's Graves disease is autoimmune thyroid,
which is you have antibodies to the thyroid, it can be in a Graves hyper, hyper T3 response
or Hashimoto's, hypo T3 response, still antibodies to the thyroid tissue, same thing with the brain,
same thing with the bones, you're talking about joint capsule, antibodies, rheumatoid disease,
ankle oceid spondylitis, other arthritis that are inflammatory, the list goes on.
So it's basically what you have antibodies created against, you have antibodies created against
this tissue then it's given a different name, it's still the same thing, you know, it's a
different thing meaning you're going to have an attack on that organ that you have antibodies
against, but the treatment is going to be the same, you can't, you know, stimulate an immune
response in any of these cases, so you have a friend that has rheumatoid arthritis and it might
not even be tied to Lyme or anything at all, you can't be given them a whole bunch of vitamin C therapy
in immune stimulants and echinacea and stuff like that on a regular basis, you're just making them
worse, you have to give anti-inflammatory, so we'll walk through that pathway. There's lots of
drugs that are out for autoimmune diseases, most of them do very similar things, they're trying to
calm that immune response at that area, so that's why most people with acute autoimmune disease
are going to be given steroids because that will be the fastest way to calm an immune response,
except it's just not sustainable, it causes all sorts of problems, including cancer in the long run,
so they're looking for other drugs for these different diseases. From a functional standpoint,
there's really four things that you're looking at, healing the barriers,
calming the triggers, modulating the immune response and going along with that is that you're not
stimulating the immune response and decreasing the inflammation usually through diet and through the
use of anti-inflammatory nutrients like flavonoids, so healing the barriers, the biggest barriers that
you're talking about with autoimmune response that you're trying to calm down is the blood
brain barrier that is made up by the astrocytes of the brain and the gut barrier, so you've heard of
leaky gut syndrome, so we're not going to go into these things in detail, but you have to work on
healing these barriers, so it's not an easy task, it is a long-term task, it's something that you constantly
work on, it's not something that you're finished with, now there's some specific products, nutrients
that can help heal astrocytes and help heal that damaged blood brain barrier, but it is a long-term
thing, it's not like, oh, I took this for two months and now my blood brain barrier is healed,
it doesn't work that way, leaky gut is a constant thing too because we have constant damage,
you have antibodies, different proteins or peptides that you're consuming or you're exposed to,
you're constantly causing inflammation in the gut and constantly causing damage, you have stress,
you have hormone imbalances, you have infections in the gut, you have different toxins that you're
exposed to and drugs that you're using that you might need antibodies or antibiotics in themselves
are great to kill a cute line, but they damaged the gut barrier, so they got negative connotations,
you're eating GMO foods, you're basically taking an antibiotic on a daily basis, so you can't drink
the city water of any major city and not be exposed to a lot of different drugs that is damaging
your blood brain barrier and your gut barrier, so you're constantly having to work at healing these
barriers because they're constantly being damaged, then you absolutely need to calm the triggers,
and that's why I'm so adamant about getting antibody testing, getting food sensitive testing,
looking at the Syrex 10, looking at all the Syrex arrays that can show that there are triggers,
either environmental triggers that are like two glyphosates, two other herbicides and pesticides
two different heavy metals, two the most common thing is to foods, so you're eating foods that oh I
don't get a tummy ache and I have normal bowel movements, but you're causing this virus and the gut
that's damaging the barrier that's causing all sorts of inflammatory products and inflammation that's
taking place in the brain and the rest of the body and we could just go on and nausea about that,
so so important, and then looking at modulating the immune response, this is very confusing,
charge here which talks about the innate immune system, that's basically your TH1 immediate response
to kill pathogens, and then you have your B cell or adaptive immune response, and that's the main
purpose of that is to make antibodies to then be able to take a pathogens so that your immediate
innate response, your TH1 system can kick back on and kill that pathogen because it's able to find
it because it's tagged, you have your TH17 cell response which is more so in the brain, and it is
tied more so a lot of research with autoimmune issues, but we're talking about modulating the immune
system, we're talking about your T-reg cells, trying to stimulate T-regulation to calm a hyper immune
system down, we're really speaking with autoimmune disease, we're trying to calm down that innate
immune response, calm down the pro-inflammatory cytokine response, so this modulating the immune
response ties to decreasing inflammation because that pro-inflammatory response is going to be very
hyper inflammatory, hence the name, so we're trying to calm that down, so you're using things like
vitamin D as far as a nutraceutical for this, and many of the mushrooms can be
immune modulating response, can be very helpful in this, and a decreasing inflammation
of a picture of food, this anti-inflammatory diet can be really helpful, but really from a nutritional
standpoint, from a nutritional standpoint, you're talking about using the flavonoids, so the
curcumin, the resveratrol, the green tea extract, the white willow bark, the other pine barks,
the corsetins, these type of things that I didn't name them all help decrease that immune response
all throughout the body, this is what you'd use the same thing that you'd use for microglial priming,
if you watched that video, if you didn't go back a couple modules and watch about microglial priming,
so important with inflammation of the brain, so this is how you have to treat this, it is a long
term thing, when you're talking about phase three autoimmune disease, you're not talking about
having your autoimmune disease go away, that's not what we're talking about, we're talking about
managing this autoimmune disease, this is a lifelong management of this, this isn't cure, so we're not
talking about a cure for an autoimmune response, or an autoimmune disease, we're talking about proper
management, so get that through, our understanding, not that God can't heal us, God can heal anybody at
any time, but when you're talking about things that you're going to do for an autoimmune disease,
you're talking about proper management of an autoimmune disease, so you're not getting these flares,
your symptoms are getting less and less, and like I tell autoimmune patients for years, we want
your good days now to be like your bad days in a year or so, but we're talking, it could be years
before you start to feel better, you have to manage that understanding, it's really really important,
okay watch the videos in this module and we'll be forward, and know that I'll be praying for you
and have a blessed day.